(dramatic music)
- Imagine you're getting
ready to go to the gym,
you grab your keys and your bag,
and then you take a supplement,
and you feel like it's working.
It might be working a little too well.
What you don't know is
that this supplement,
one that you bought at the health aisle
at your grocery store is laced
with an anabolic steroid,
an illegal drug invisibly
mixed into this powder.
In recent years researchers have been
grabbing thousands
of different supplements off the shelf,
and testing them to see what's inside.
And what they found
in over 3000 supplements that they tested
is that 28% had some sort
of illegal substance,
mostly steroids, meaning the
people that are taking them
are unintentionally doping.
In another study, 92% of the
supplements that were tested
by scientists were
contaminated with bacteria.
87% had fungal contamination,
And when they tested CBD supplements
they found that 55% of the
oils had either way more
or way less CBD than stated on the label.
And a few of them even had THC in them,
the thing that gets you high.
And it turns out the government
here in the United States
doesn't seem to care.
So how did we get here?
And why are shady companies,
influencer campaigns
and targeted advertisements
selling Americans things
to put in their body
that aren't what they say they are,
and that are potentially dangerous?
And I guess a big question for me is
which of these are actually
necessary or healthy?
And which of them are dangerous?
And is this all just a waste of money?
(gentle music)
Hey, pause really quick.
You know how we started this video
with this hypothetical scenario
that I'm drinking workout supplements?
Well, I actually do workout now.
For the first time in my adult life
I am kind of buff.
The sponsor of today's
video is the reason why.
Thank you CoPilot for
sponsoring the video.
This is a game changer.
CoPilot is a platform that pairs you up
with your very own fitness coach.
My coach is named Devon,
he's great.
You meet with your coach,
and you tell them what you want.
For me, I don't wanna get buff,
but I want to be able
to like lift my body,
and be like strong and not have back pain.
And he designed a full-blown like workout,
and he can customize it and change it,
and I communicate with him.
There's no decision making here.
You press go,
and it guides you through your workout
with little video examples so you know
exactly what you're supposed
to do for exactly how long,
and then you move on to the next thing.
Over the months your workout will change
as you give feedback
to your personal coach,
who's always tinkering with it
based on what you want to do,
what you don't like, what you like.
It turns out that accountability
is basically the key to
keeping a workout routine,
having someone to stand accountable to.
And that's the major
benefit to this in my mind
is there's a real human being
who's checking in on me.
"Are you working out?"
But it's also really nice
to have a professional
taking all the guesswork
out of my workouts.
So CoPilot is awesome,
I'm grateful for them
sponsoring today's video.
I'm grateful they exist.
I'm grateful that I can do 10
pull-ups now because of them.
And if you want to try this out
there's a nice sweet discount
that they're giving to all
the viewers of my channel
if they click the link in the description,
and they sign up before February 1st.
You get 14 days for free to try this out
with your own personalized coach,
see if it works for you.
And 20% off your first month.
So you can try it out at as a discount,
see if it works for you.
But, again, use the
link in my description,
because doing so gets you the discount,
it helps support the channel.
And do it before February 1st.
Okay, that's it.
Let's dive in to this
story about supplements.
(drum bangs)
It's easy to look at stuff like this,
and say it's kind of like medicine,
and so it would be kind of
regulated like medicine,
tracked and vetted by our
government's health agency
like medicine is.
But medicine goes through
a very different process,
a super lengthy process
with tons of studies
and clinical trials, paperwork.
It takes years and years,
and a lot of drugs aren't
ever even approved.
They fail this process,
and never make it onto the shelf.
But supplements don't
have to do any of that.
- Companies are responsible for ensuring
their products are safe,
and in fact can often
put new dietary supplements on the market
without even telling FDA.
- There are rules on
what supplement companies
are allowed to put in
their pills and gummies,
but these rules aren't
enforced in any real way.
It's up to the supplement
company to obey them.
- With dietary supplements
it's on the honor system
that they are following
those rules and regulations.
- That's Dr. C. Michael White,
- A pharmacist, distinguished professor
and chair of pharmacy practice
at the University of
Connecticut School of Pharmacy.
- And this is Dr. F. Perry Wilson.
- I am a physician and researcher
here at Yale University.
(bell dings)
- These two doctors helped
us a lot in our reporting,
helped us navigate this
really complex topic,
and helped us better understand
how this $50 billion a year industry
runs wild with all of these products
that make health claims
that are often not backed up by anything.
There's a wild story on how we got here,
and to understand it we
have to go back to the 80's
and 90's to understand
this political commercial
featuring Mel Gibson
and health supplements.
- It's only vitamins.
- [Reporter] Nelson Mandela
got a rousing welcome
from the city of New York today.
- The East German authorities have said
the Berlin Wall doesn't
mean anything anymore.
- Oh yeah.
- The 90's was a time of
economic prosperity in America,
which fueled the rise
of a health conscious middle class
that was increasingly
attracted to health foods
and fitness regimes,
and alternative medicine.
- I avoid sugar,
that makes me feel good about me.
- To cater to this shift,
you have this supplement industry,
which was very small
and niche at the time,
but they met the demand
of this new middle class
and began diversifying their offerings.
They expanded beyond the
typical vitamin C tablets
and echinacea drops,
introducing a variety of new substances,
each purporting to enhance
one's life in unique ways.
One of the supplements
that gained popularity
was called L-Tryptophan.
It was this health food supplement
made of amino acids that claimed to
help people sleep and lose weight.
It sounded healthy enough
until doctors found that
people who took the stuff
were developing blood
and muscle disorders.
Investigations found that it
led to the death of 38 people.
In response to this incident,
Congress began drafting laws
that would tighten regulation
on health supplements.
So they drafted this bill.
The bill would give more power to the FDA
to regulate these companies,
to tighten the rules on how supplements
were able to be labeled,
what claims they could make.
But, as we know,
whenever there's a growing industry
that's making a lot of
money off of selling things
and the government comes in
and tries to regulate them,
they don't just sit
back and let it happen.
So all the supplement
companies got together,
they held these emergency meetings,
they sent an army of
lobbyists to Washington,
and they started pouring
money on commercials.
- Help make sure your child
gets a balanced diet with Flintstones.
- And this is where Mel Gibson,
the 90's movie star, comes into the story.
(gentle music)
- [Officer] Freeze.
- Hey guys, guys, it's
got it's only vitamins.
Vitamin C, you know, like in oranges.
- [Narrator] If you don't
wanna lose your vitamins,
make the FDA stop.
- Yeah, they weren't messing around here.
They published books,
they sent flyers to people's mailboxes.
They produced more commercials,
they created petitions to rally Americans
around their supplements,
and it worked.
More and more Americans
were taking supplements,
and they responded to
this potential tightening of regulation,
and all of this fear
mongering by the lobbyists
by writing to Congress,
telling the government not
to regulate supplements,
to let them keep their vitamins.
At the same time, these lobbyists
targeted the lawmakers themselves,
convincing them to oppose the legislation
that was under consideration in Congress,
and to actually counter it
by passing their own law,
a law that would be
friendly to the industry.
And you can actually see this point blank.
Sometimes lobbying is foggy,
and we don't know what happened,
but in this case the senators
who received the most money
from the industry were the ones
who actually drafted the
new bill for this law.
And here it is.
Public law 103-417 from October 25, 1994.
So what started as an attempt
to regulate supplements
actually turned into a law
that is friendly to the industry,
and the reason we have this.
(dramatic music)
I mean I love when you're neck
deep in one of these laws,
and you just see a statement
that just makes it so clear
who was influencing this law.
Check this out.
This law just straight up says
that the federal government should not
take any actions to impose
unreasonable regulatory
barriers towards this industry.
And especially, says the law,
this industry is really lucrative.
It has annual sales of $4 billion.
Congress wouldn't wanna slow that down.
So then the big kicker here,
one of the key parts of the law is that
they specify that supplements,
the thing in this bottle is
not classified as medicine,
it's classified as food.
That's how the FDA
should treat it, as food.
But supplements are not food
in the same way a bag of Doritos is food,
they're much more complicated.
But we'll get back to that in a sec.
The point is that this
law gave the industry
a lot of freedom,
including what kind of
claims they could make.
The law gave them the authority
to say a lot of things
about what their health
supplement does for people
as long as they include
this one disclaimer.
I'm looking at Genius Mushrooms.
The product says that it is
healthy immune system support,
energy and clarity.
Sounds great.
But then here on the back
in very, very, very small,
teeny tiny, almost illegible font,
zoom in here, you will
see a teeny tiny statement
that complies with the law.
These statements have not been evaluated
by the food administrator.
This product is not intended to diagnose.
It's right there in the fine print
that no one is reading.
What people are reading is this.
Healthy immune system
support, energy and clarity.
I mean, the law is so
friendly to the industry.
It allows these companies
to effectively regulate themselves.
The law makes it clear
that it's the government's job
to go prove that something
is adulterated or wrong
rather than making the companies prove
that their products are safe
before they go to market.
I mean it's totally backwards.
- We do not approve them for safety
and effectiveness before they are sold.
Companies are responsible
for ensuring their products are safe.
- So thanks to this 1994 law
supplement makers were very happy
because now they don't have
to tell the FDA anything.
They don't have to prove that
their claims are effective,
they just have to put a little
tiny fine print disclaimer.
And the FDA has no real
enforcement regime.
They only really step in in a big way
after the supplement is
proven to be hurting people.
Any authority they do have
to check on the supplements has to be done
with their shoestring budget.
This was Congress
giving the supplement
industry a blank check,
telling them they can do what you want,
we can't regulate you,
it's now the law.
And this is why the industry went from
a $4 billion industry in the early 90's
to a $53 billion industry today.
This is why Americans are now
inundated with capsules
and pills and drops and creams
and teas that claim to
make your body work better.
But this is confusing
because supplements actually
do have a place in our lives
for certain people who need certain things
that their body can't make.
So one of my questions
going into all of this is
what of this is legit?
Is any of it,
or is it all just snake oil?
What does the science actually say?
(gentle music)
There's been a lot of good study on this,
and luckily we got one
of those amazing things
where they do a study
of all of the studies,
and they put it all together,
and they say
"This is what all the studies
"have concluded over the years."
Like a good old meta-analysis.
This meta-analysis,
which used 84 studies,
and put it all together
to find conclusions,
found that vitamins and supplements
were generally, quote,
associated with little
or no benefit in preventing cancer,
cardiovascular disease and death.
It had a little bit
of a benefit on treating cancer
if you already have it.
They also found that people
with a high risk of lung cancer
had a, quote, increased
risk of lung cancer
and other harmful outcomes
by taking one vitamin, betacarotene.
So what this basically is saying
is that vitamins don't work
for the big things,
preventing the killers like
cancer and heart problems.
And they maybe even hurt us in some cases,
depending on the supplement.
But in reading these
conclusions you start to realize
just how complex this is.
There are like thousands
of different supplements,
and there are innumerable
numbers of individual bodies
that have different chemistry
and different experiences.
It starts to get confusing
to find a satisfying conclusion.
So we asked our experts
do supplements actually make
us healthier in any way?
- Many doctors would suggest
that you don't need to
take supplements at all,
unless you have a deficiency.
- Ah deficiency, that's the key word here.
So maybe my body doesn't
naturally produce enough
vitamin C or I don't get it in my food,
then a supplement would be useful.
- If you're a strict vegan,
you have very strong dietary restrictions
for whatever reason,
those people probably are good candidates
for taking a multivitamin.
- That's a situation where
it makes a lot of sense.
But most of us don't need to do that.
Whenever there's a situation
where all the humans in a society
need a certain substance
that they're not getting,
the government goes
wild to make it happen.
Like there was a time when we
all were deficient in iodine,
so to fix this the government
worked with salt makers
to just put iodine in salt.
So now all of us use it all the time,
and we just have enough iodine
because there's iodine in all of our salt.
I guess what I'm saying here
is that most of us check
off all of our vitamins
and mineral needs by living
and eating a variety of foods.
But, of course, within our
population there are people
who can't produce enough
of a certain vitamin,
or like this YouTuber
who just ate chicken
tenders every single day.
I mean they should probably
take some vitamins.
You have to eat a variety of foods
to get all your vitamins and minerals.
And luckily here in the 21st century
we have a test to find out
how you're doing on this.
It's a blood test.
They take your blood, they test it,
and they find out how you're
doing on vitamins and minerals,
and what you might be deficient in,
and thus what supplements
might actually work for you.
And yet 252 million Americans
are popping $53 billion worth
of supplements every year,
and most of them probably don't
need to be taking anything.
Okay, so if I don't need all this,
but I'm taking a fistful
of vitamins every day,
where does it all go?
- You're just peeing
out all of the excess.
And it might give you
glow in the dark urine,
which is pretty cool,
but it's a large waste of your dollars.
- Here's a full disclosure
that may be surprising to you.
I take vitamins and supplements sometimes.
I got sent this green
powder from a sponsor
who's thinking about sponsoring
a video on the channel,
and I totally drank it every day.
It's a vitamin supplement.
It has a billion different vitamins in it.
And I was like "Maybe I need one of these
"even though my blood
test doesn't say I do,
"what if I actually do?
"What if it's actually gonna help?"
And I tell you that to let you know
that this isn't easy.
This is not an easy thing to navigate.
We were hit with all of these messages
of improve your mental
clarity, increased energy.
And you're just like
"Is any of this real?"
What I'm finding is
that most of it is not.
But what to me is ethically wrong
is when people turn to supplements
because they've been lied to
or because they don't trust
or can't afford other forms of treatment.
In other words, when they're desperate.
- Surveys of American sentiment show
that pharmaceutical companies
have lower approval ratings than Congress,
which is, that's pretty bad.
And, again, in many ways rightly so.
The profiteering off medications is,
in my opinion, quite unethical.
- So we hate pharmaceutical companies
for good reason, maybe,
but we suddenly trust
supplement companies?
We trust vitamins,
and the industry that makes them?
Okay, so just quick recap.
Supplements are the wild
west in the United States.
They've been very poorly regulated.
The industry's gone wild.
They can make these wild claims.
And a lot of us are
maybe wasting our money,
and peeing out supplements
that we don't need.
Is that the scope of the problem here,
just that we're wasting our money
and we're being falsely advertised to?
Doesn't seem that bad.
(dramatic music)
That is until you realize
that not all supplements are harmless.
The law says that supplements
should be regulated like food,
but they aren't food.
There's a lot of complicated work
that goes into creating a
high quality, safe supplement.
It's a complex process of manufacturing,
making sure that the substances are pure,
the dosage is correct,
and it can go wrong very easily.
- 23,000 people a year, in
fact, go to the emergency room
after taking a supplement.
- Supplement makers don't have to prove
that their products are safe.
- It was unbelievable what we found.
- [Reporter] False and
unsubstantiated claims.
- Remember L-Tryptophan back in the 80's
people were taking it,
and they were thinking it was
gonna help with their insomnia
and helping them lose weight,
and yet it caused thousands of illnesses
and dozens of deaths.
One of the big problems with that
was likely due to contamination
within the supplement,
not necessarily the substance itself.
A few years ago there was
a supplement that came out
that was supposed to
regulate blood circulation,
but it ended up having lead in it.
It caused all sorts of lead poisoning,
and two deaths.
A few years later,
the FDA seized 300,000 dietary supplements
because they had an excessive
amount of lead in them.
That was from one corporation.
The FDA isn't monitoring
all of these supplements,
but luckily scientists are.
There's this 2018 study
that found that 92% of the
supplements that they studied
had bacterial contamination,
and 87% had fungal contamination,
which can be really
damaging for your body.
I'm not gonna go down a
whole literature review here
because there's so much of this.
Let's just say there's a lot of instances
of supplements being
found to be contaminated.
(dramatic music)
Okay, let me just tell
you one more example here
that is just such a good
example of the abuse
of the lack of regulation here.
There's this one plant called Kratom.
I don't know, here in the
US I like feel like I see it
everywhere, in every strip mall.
It's like Kratom Signs.
It's made from this evergreen tree leaf,
and it's sold in the form of powder
and pills and extracts.
It sounds totally natural and fresh,
and I can see why it's
doing so well on the market.
But, once again, Kratom has been linked
to hundreds of cases of
salmonella poisoning,
and there's the fact that
it's highly addictive,
especially to those who
have had opioid addictions,
which is, if you haven't heard,
a giant problem in our country.
It has been deemed to
be the cause of death
for 91 people who had
overdoses in 2016 and 2017,
though only seven of
those people were found
to only have kratom in their body.
There were other drugs
in the overdose as well.
But what we're saying here is that
this can be dangerous stuff.
It's not just food like
the law wants it to be.
The FDA urged the DEA to classify this
as a schedule one drug,
which is the classification for heroin,
but it's a dietary supplement
just down the road at the
local convenience store.
Speaking of drugs, some
supplements are kind of
just like drugs in disguise.
- So what we're really seeing is
that in a lot of those cases
they're putting in synthetic drugs,
which sometimes are prescription drugs,
and sometimes are products that are not
approved by the FDA.
- One study found that
over the last decade
more than 750 supplements were
illegally spiked with drugs.
Only half of them were ever recalled.
Wait, why can they do this?
Why can they just put
drugs, illegal drugs,
into supplements?
Ah, because of this law.
This law that the industry
helped pass in the 90's that says
that none of this has to get
any approval from the FDA.
The FDA only steps in
when something goes wrong,
when the damage is already done.
So backwards.
And these companies can
get pretty aggressive.
A few years ago, the
academics who revealed
that these supplement companies
were spiking their
supplements with illegal drugs
got sued by one of these companies,
a company called
High-Tech Pharmaceuticals.
The company ended up losing the lawsuit,
but what it revealed is that
this company had been selling a product
that they had been ordered
to stop selling, to recall,
and they just never did.
There's so little
oversight happening here.
And, again, it's a giant
industry, with a lot of money
and a lot of products,
and it's an FDA that is very
small, with very little money,
and not a lot of authority to do much.
And as we mentioned at the
very beginning of the video,
when researchers went in
and just popped open some of these bottles
and studied the pills,
they found that a lot of these supplements
don't actually have
what they say they have.
They're a totally different substance,
but none of us know because
you don't know what calcium tastes like.
- Literally there have been studies
that have shown some supplements have
no detectable amount of
the thing that it says
is supposed to be in there.
- No detectable amount.
And then we've got good old melatonin.
I love melatonin when I need it.
That gummy that helps us all
get a good night's sleep.
But it's not a sleeping pill, right?
Because it's like natural.
- [Reporter] Melatonin
poisonings in children
have been on the rise
over the past decade.
- Well actually melatonin
is not a vitamin,
it is a hormone that
you naturally produce.
It helps induce sleep.
And it's kind of been trending
over the last few years,
especially among children.
Over the past decade,
the number of children
who have overdosed on
melatonin went up 530%,
causing kids to experience symptoms
like vomiting and diarrhea.
A lot of that is because
of dosage problems.
In some cases they found
that the dose is 50% higher
than what was on the label.
- [Reporter] The US Food
and Drug Administration
doesn't have any control
of the ingredients
or the accuracy of dosage claims.
- We talked to one guy
who started a Reddit forum
because he was taking Lions Mane,
which is a mushroom supplement,
and it was causing a mysterious illness.
He thought it was going to give him energy
and mental clarity like
it says on the bottle,
but instead what he experienced
was heart palpitations,
sleepless nights.
- I couldn't sleep for
eight months straight.
By that I say one more than
one or two hours a night.
- When he started the subreddit,
he found thousands of others
who reported a whole host
of neurological issues,
chronic tension headaches,
a lack of emotion.
One user's husband took his life
after not being able to sleep,
having constant panic attacks,
and losing his job over it.
He was 43.
- I'd been to the hospital about 20 times
the first two months.
I have seen basically every specialist
that I could get ahold of,
and really nobody could
tell me what was going on.
- These people come to Reddit
because they don't have any answers.
They bought a supplement
that looked legitimate,
promising mental clarity,
and focus and energy,
and had their lives completely changed.
That's because our government failed.
We have a government to protect us
against exactly these types of things.
But instead people are turning
to Reddit to find answers.
To me this is the most atrocious
version of supplements.
We actually reached out to the FDA
as a part of this story to
understand what's the deal?
Why is it like this?
And they responded,
and we scheduled an interview.
We were gonna discuss dietary supplements
and regulation in the United States,
but then the day before the interview
they canceled our meeting,
and then just ghosted us.
Luckily we have clips
of former FDA commissioners
talking about this,
and they all seem to agree
that this is a problem
of authority and resources.
- Will the FDA ever
regulate this industry?
- We tried.
(gentle music)
- So, what can be done here?
Well, luckily we live in a system
where we can make change by changing laws.
Like in the 90's we almost did this.
If the Congress had
given the FDA more power
we would have stricter punishments
for supplement companies
who break the rules.
We would have better rules
around what they can sell,
and what claims they can make.
- We should at least be able to agree
that all the companies
should have to prove
that they don't have bacterial
or fungal contamination,
that they don't have heavy metals,
that they're not containing
prescription drugs,
and that they do contain the product
in the dose that's specified in the pills
that they're putting on their label.
- I would like purity,
and that people know what they're getting.
I mean we owe it to
consumers at the very least
that if you're gonna choose to buy it
you should at least know
what you're getting.
That seems like the bare minimum,
and right now that's not the case.
- The experts we talked to don't think
that supplements should
be regulated like drugs.
I think that makes sense.
But they agree that we should start
with giving the FDA the authority
and the resources it needs
to monitor supplements so we
know what's actually in them,
so that we're not
trusting the honor system
of for-profit companies to obey the rules,
and to actually put in these supplements
what they say is in these supplements.
This would mean the FDA going
and conducting spot checks more often
and more aggressively to make sure
that this stuff is correct,
and that it's being
manufactured in a clean way,
free of contamination.
Congress has recently considered a bill
that would help with this,
including trying to create a database
of all the supplements
so that the FDA at least
knows what's on the market.
But, of course, the supplement
lobby's not gonna stand back.
They spend over $2 million
a year on lobbying,
making sure that things
stay the way they are.
They make a lot of money off it.
So, if you are one of the many millions
who take a bunch of supplements,
and are not sure if they're
spiked with weird stuff,
or if you even need them, what do you do?
And the answer is go
get your blood tested,
and just see if you're
deficient in anything,
if you actually need a dietary supplement.
And even if your blood test comes back
and you don't need anything,
I believe that people should be able
to consume whatever they want,
even if it's not scientifically proven.
You know your body, you
should be able to take
whatever vitamin or mineral
you feel is working for you.
I just think that when you
have a for-profit industry
that is free to mislead and deceive
and prey on consumers,
you get a bunch of bad situations
like the ones we've talked about here.
So until the government steps in
to help us navigate this,
we're kind of on our own.
I'm gonna put some
links in the description
to third party websites that you can go to
to look up your supplements,
the specific supplements,
and see if they've passed
a high quality standard
to know if at least you're getting
what it says on the bottle.
So that's where we're at with supplements.
We're here waiting for
transparency and accountability,
and above all waiting for the regard
of others' wellbeing over
the interests of an industry
that seems to care more about
profit than about our health.
(gentle music)
Thanks for watching the video everyone.
Thank you CoPilot for
sponsoring today's video.
CoPilot found that people
are nine times more likely
to stick with a workout routine
if they're actually
accountable to a human being
that checks in with me,
that asks me how it's going.
That makes all of the difference.
There's a link in my description,
it gets you 14 days for free
with your own personal
health and fitness coach.
So you can try it out for
free, see if it works,
and cancel if it doesn't work,
and stick with it if it does.
Thanks to all of our supporters
over at The Newsroom,
which is our Patreon.
I deeply appreciate your
support every month.
For those who want to learn more,
there's a link in the description.
We sell LUTs and presets,
which is how we color
our videos and photos.
I have a poster that is a bunch
of maps that's really fun,
and we started a new
channel called Search Party
with my old colleague Sam Ellis,
and it's really good.
That's all, thanks for being here.
See ya.
(gentle music)